joining us now only on cbs this morning
are tim dunn and charlotte charles
it's good to see you both again i'm so
sorry that two years later
we still don't have answers for you in
this case but you should know we've
never forgotten your son and never
forgotten that story
help us understand though charlotte
you'll start it off start us off please
what the last two years have been like
for you
they're no easier now the days are no
easier now than what they were
um we've moved forward
with the cases both civil and and
criminal
since we were last on here but the pain
and the suffering
is is getting worse if anything um the
continued fight
exhausting time yeah absolutely the same
i
it's worse every day i i'm
struggling with my life at home
my wife tracy has to put up with me i'm
i'm
argumentative i'm sad all the time i
struggle to get motivated yeah i'm
really
really struggling at the minute yeah we
understand that you know the thing that
struck me last time charlotte you were
here
you said listen i understand that this
was a terrible accident
that ansakul ansa coolest behind the
wheel i understand that
but what i don't understand is why she
hasn't said anything to us
or reached out to us at the time you
said if she would just apologize i don't
even want her to go to jail you said
yeah do you do you still feel that we
still stand by that
we do still stand by that but we've
still had no direct contact
you know and we've we've known for a
long long time now that she's able
to return to the uk of her own volition
to face
uk justice but still what would you like
we would like her to engage with the uk
justice system
just like we wanted right from the
beginning just to get to the starting
block
what happens after that we have no
control over that
but we're just asking her to get to the
starting block
her lawyer has said that they offered to
have her complete community service in
the uk
as part of a plea deal i imagine as well
as make a contribution in harry's name
and charlotte you said that's not enough
why do you draw the line there well
firstly we don't have any control over
we don't we don't have plea bargaining
in the uk so it's not
like you can go to to a courtroom rad
would be able to talk to you more about
this
and say look you know if i do this can
we make sure
we don't work like that in the uk our
crown prosecution
service deal with the charges and a
court of law
deal with what's handed down
seeing as we have no control over that
we just need her to get to the starting
what happens after that is is of no
concern to us
tim what does justice look like to you
is there a certain
punishment or amount of time that you
think she should serve and also
is there a conversation that you're
ready to have at all
like charlotte says i i really i'm the
same mind i
i'm not worried if there's any prisoners
time or anything like that
i just want her to own accountability
for what she has done to us as a family
and to my son and i need to
ask her why she left why did she think
it was okay to
[Music]
leave my son there and and and just
leave the country i
it still hurts after two years not
knowing these answers
um i feel like my son's life was just
i don't want to be horrible but like it
was meant nothing to her
and i'm sure that's not the case she's a
mother as well she's a mother herself
and i would think i don't know her we've
never talked to her i would imagine
maybe she panicked i
i don't know i don't know but you're
saying despite that
she should say something to you you know
we just saw that boris johnson had
mentioned it to
president biden did you know he was
going to do that no have you had any
conversation with boris johnson
um no certainly not no no would you like
to talk to boris johnson too
absolutely and he said he'd mentioned it
to the biden administration any comments
from the biden administration to you all
not directly no i mean we we were
really pleased that it was raised that
harry was raised on the eve of g7
we didn't dare dream that harry would be
raised you know in such global issues
we found out from the media so we were
heartened
to hear it but a little bit disappointed
that we found out the way
we did but nonetheless it's a positive
step forward
um yes everything we've been through
since we've been here
the last few days you know is a positive
step forward
where we feel so welcomed
by the us people again we feel
um so grateful for for all of the
support that we're getting both from the
media and from
from all of your citizens out there i do
think the us cares about this case
which is why we're still talking to you
today i know you've been up for the last
three days i know you've been traveling
you haven't slept you had depositions
which is always traumatic always
traumatic regardless of what the case is
and can you tell us anything about the
depositions what that process was like
for you
um just that we had no idea um a few
weeks ago what what
a deposition even was thankfully to to
um to our us lawyers we've been
as prepared as possible about what a
deposition
is um nonetheless of course it was
grueling
you know you're you're there talking
about your son
um it's really hard
you know you're trying to to get across
to
them how loved he was yeah
how much we loved him how much he's
missed
um so for the for the best part
everything was focused on harry and i
never feel we can go too far wrong
when we always keep harry at the center
you know at the front focus on stories
yeah
in in harry's memory i know it's
important to think about safety on the
road with motorcycles you've got a
motorcycle pin there what do you want
people to know
so things like this don't happen again
um we're working really really closely
actually with our transport secretary
in the uk government and he's making
sure that
full road reviews in and around all of
the american bases
in the uk are looked at
there are a lot of recommendations that
have already come to light
we're working really hard behind the
scenes we're juggling a lot of bulls at
the moment to try and make sure
that this doesn't happen again we talked
about the meeting at the white house you
said
left you with emotional scars
yeah yeah um number one we didn't
realize we were going to see
president trump you know we got told it
was a senior official we had the call
within hours of being on your show the
first time
maybe there are back channel
conversations going on that will put you
in the same room with aunt sepulos
maybe maybe maybe but we need
you know the mediators and the
therapists around us but not only for us
but for her too charlotte and tim thank
you so much for coming back
thank you thank you appreciate it really
really thank you thank you